[Music]
what will be the amount of water
accumulated in an hour
one hard way would be to count the
number of drops and calculate still a
better way let's say we analyze the
situation and get that the rate of drops
falling per minute is constant it is 100
drops per minute then we can easily find
the answer in an hour
6000 drops will be accumulated but what
if the rate is not constant or if the
water is flowing continuously let's
consider another situation we want to
find the number of vehicles traveling on
this road in a day on a busy highway we
can think of the stream of vehicles as a
continuous quantity like water so we see
that the problem could rise when we have
to add a continuous quantity or even a
discrete one addition of numbers is one
of the most basic things that we learn
in our childhood we get more efficient
and faster at it once we learned how to
multiply numbers but when addition
becomes continuous we have to upgrade
the skill in this video and a few
upcoming ones we will take our skill of
addition to the next level the upgrade
is called the process of integration do
you remember certain one of our previous
videos we saw that integration is used
to find the area or the volume of
different shapes so how can it be used
to solve this problem actually these two
things are connected to each other there
is a relation between geometry and
addition for example we can easily count
the number of points currently on the
screen but what if I ask you to count
now you could say that this question is
absurd we cannot count the number of
points of a line as its continuous for
any two points on it we can always find
a point between them so instead of total
number of dots
we define the length of a line this was
just a glimpse of the idea let's see
what exactly do we mean by this I want
you to imagine a situation recently you
are hooked to a video game as you keeps
winning you are rewarded with points and
you just want to keep collecting them
you wonder how many points you would
collect after three weeks luckily the
game has a feature that shows the rate
at which you are earning the points it
shows that after t weeks your rate is T
squared thousand points per week so
assuming that you keep earning points at
this rate how many points will you have
after three weeks you could probably say
it's easy from this relation we can find
the rate for each week in week one
the rate will be thousand points per
week in week two 4000 points per week
and in week three it will be nine
thousand so according to these rates in
the first week the points earned will be
a thousand in the second week four
thousand and in the third week nine
thousand so fourteen thousand points in
total but is this correct
actually not in these calculations we
directly assumed that the rate is
constant during each week but it's not
constant this function implies that the
rate is continuously growing its graph
looks like this so how do we find the
total number of points for this we need
to understand what does this calculation
tell us graphically let's continue this
in the next part
look at this graph sure we have the
number of weeks on the x-axis and the
rate of earning points on the y-axis
this calculation implies that the rate
is constant during each week so it can
be represented by the horizontal lines
like this now notice one interesting
thing look at these rectangles the area
of the first rectangle will be equal to
the total number of points earned in the
first week how the height of this
rectangle is equal to the rate of one
thousand points per week and its width
is equal to one week so its area will be
equal to one multiplied by one thousand
which equals one thousand points so we
see that the area below these horizontal
lines tells us the total number of
points earned during that duration can
you find the areas of the other two
rectangles for the second rectangle it
will be equal to four thousand points
and for the third it will be nine
thousand points so we get the sum of the
areas of these three rectangles to be
equal to fourteen thousand points this
is the answer we got using this
calculation so we see that the process
of addition here simply becomes finding
the total area covered by these
rectangles but now we know that the rate
is not constant during each week notice
in the graph that in each week the
actual rate is lower than the rate we
considered here consider the first half
of week one here the rate will not be
equal to thousand points per week at the
end of the first half of week one the
rate will be one-fourth of a thousand
that is 250 points per week so let's
consider this as the constant rate
throughout the first half of week one
instead of one thousand this will give
us a better estimate of total number of
points can you tell me the total points
earned in this duration yes it will be
equal to the area of fistrick
tangle 125 points if we do this for each
half of all the three weeks we will get
this graph now we know that the total
points earned will be equal to the sum
of the areas of these rectangles after
doing these calculations and adding we
will get the answer as 11,000 375 points
earlier we got the total as 14,000
points and now it's this number this is
a better estimate than the previous one
because the rate considered here is
closer to the graph so what should we do
next to improve our estimate further
correct
it's the consider an even shorter
duration of a week for example a day we
will get an even better estimate as we
keep decreasing the width of the
rectangles further we see that this
total area will approach the area under
this curve so we see that the problem of
finding the total number of reward
points becomes the problem of finding
the area under the graph of this
function this is the connection between
geometry and addition we mentioned
earlier in abstract terms we can say
that if we have a function which
represents the rate of some quantity
then the area under the graph of that
function tells us the total amount of
that quantity now we need to know how to
find the area under the graph of a
function integration is the process used
to find this area and this area is
called the integral of the function in
the next video we will see how to find
the integral of a function
do subscribe to our channel to stay
updated
[Music]